هذا التعليق هو ما نطلق
عليه اسم Planet Killer ، وهو ما نطلق عليه اسم القاتل العالمي
هوليوود يخطط لطرق
لإنقاذ العالم من المذنبات أو
الكويكبات القاتلة لعقود من الزمن ، وقد
طلبت منا حكومة الولايات المتحدة فقط إنقاذ
العالم ، أي شخص يريد أن يقول لا ولكن بدلاً من ذلك
لإحضار بروس ويليس لدى ناسا
فكرة مختلفة وهي على وشك اختبارها
لأول مرة ، إنها نوع من
ما نخشاه جميعًا ، ماذا لو كان
هناك كويكب قادم نحو الأرض ،
هل يمكنك حقًا إيقافه ، هل يمكنك فعل
شيء حقًا  حول هذا الموضوع ولأول
مرة تتيح لنا تقنيتنا
فعل شيء حيال ذلك ،
تخطط ناسا لدفع مركبة فضائية بحجم الثلاجة
تسمى دارت إلى كويكب
غير متبلور
بحجم هرم الجيزة تقريبًا ولا يشكل أي
تهديد للكوكب  الهدف من كوكب الأرض هو
معرفة ما إذا كان الاصطدام سيدفع عكس الشكل
قليلاً عن مساره إذا نجح ، فهذا يعني
أنه يمكن استخدام هذه التقنية
لصرف كويكب قاتل في المستقبل يكون
رأسه
تمثل مهمة اختبار الدفاع الكوكبي الافتتاحية هذه
لحظة رئيسية في تاريخ البشرية
لأول مرة على الإطلاق سنقوم
بتغيير مدار جسم سماوي في
مركز التحكم في مهمة الكون داخل
مختبر جونز هوبكنز للفيزياء التطبيقية
في ماريلاند ما هذا
المكان  سيكون مثل يوم التأثير أو
ليلة التأثير ، يجب أن أقول يا إلهي ،
إنه سيكون ممتلئًا على حافة الهاوية
مع أشخاص سيكون هناك أشخاص
في كل مقعد في مركز العمليات بأكمله ،
حوالي 44
شخصًا هنا بمفردهم.  سنكون قادرين على
مشاهدة التأثير على الهواء مباشرة كما سيتمكن الجميع
على الأرض بفضل الكاميرا
المثبتة على صور المركبة الفضائية الصور الحية
من Dart الآن واحدة من
أكثر اللحظات توتراً للفريق
ستحدث في 50 دقيقة للتأثير عندما
تتحول المركبة الفضائية  مشاهدها من
كويكب أكبر يتم توجيهها الآن إلى
كويكب ثانٍ أصغر وهو
الهدف الحقيقي وهذا وقت شديد العرق
بالنسبة لنا لذلك لدينا الكثير من
حالات الطوارئ التي تم إنشاؤها حول هذا
الانتقال الذي يستغرق 50 دقيقة
، سنراقب القياس عن بُعد مثل هوكس
خائفين للغاية ولكننا متحمسون ،
ثم سنقترب أكثر فأكثر
وستملأ مجال رؤية جهاز التصوير الخاص بنا
ثم  سنواجه هذه اللحظة التي
يتدرب فيها هذا الفريق منذ
شهور ولكن حتى التدريبات كانت
متوترة ، فنحن جميعًا وقفنا واحدًا تلو الآخر
مع جميع سماعات الرأس الخاصة بنا
وكنا جميعًا نشاهد الشاشات باهتمام فقط
نشاهد  أصبح الكويكب أكبر
وأكبر وكان قلبي
يخفق في الواقع لأنني كنت مثل هذا
ليس طبيعيًا ، إنها مجرد بروفة
ولكنك شعرت حقًا أنك
على وشك اصطدام ذلك الكويكب لأول
مرة تختبر فيها حقًا
التكنولوجيا التي من المحتمل أن تنقذ
البشرية جمعاء أه
على الطريق الصحيح